if you love dissonance to as much as we
did you'll be looking forward to
descendants 3 some fans have had some
awesome theories about what will happen
in it stay tuned to the end when we'll
tell you about one mystery that might be
revealed if this is your first time
visiting here then give this video a
like and subscribe to the things today
we are going to show you this is what
fans think descendants 3 will look like
will oh one of the many cool things of
the incredibly talented people who make
up the dissonance to fandom do is come
up with brilliant new characters there
are loads of examples but there's one
that we want to talk about now and it's
something that could quite possibly find
its way into dissonance 3 well we'd like
to see it it's from a story by a Wattpad
user called Harry Hook fan however while
their story does involve Harry it's the
new character who really made us sit up
and pay attention she is called willow
and there is something very special
about her
you see she isn't entirely human she is
the daughter of one of the world of
fairy tales most iconic villains can you
guess who we might be talking about
that's right it's the big bad wolf
so willow is half human and half wolf
she has the ears of a wolf and she has a
long Fuffy tail she has blue eyes and
whenever she gets angry her eyes glow
her teeth sharpen and her claws grow
even before we get into Harry Hook fans
story we really like her and want to
know what she goes on to do in the story
we learned that her mother who was human
was killed and now willow lives with her
father on the Isle of the Lost
the big bad wolf is incredibly
protective of his only daughter we also
learned that she was once friends with
Harry hook but now they are not too
close we don't want to give too much
away but we learn more about why that
was it's a really cool story it's called
Wolf's daughter and we would love to see
willow in descendants three Lumas
identity crisis when Disney made
dissonance tooth they gave us a pretty
much instant addition to the pantheon of
classic villains that character was uma
the daughter of Ursula uma fast became
the character that moderns
Disney fans love to hate descendants fan
Ranger Wolfgang certainly gravitated
towards her and came up with an idea
based on her story and where it might go
in descendants three it starts with uma
suffering from a real crisis of
confidence she finds herself trying to
deal with who she is and how she is most
of her pirate crew has disbanded but she
still has Gill and Harry as her loyal
psychics but things are changing on the
Isle of the Lost
there's a new ruler in the shape of
Shenmue the son of Xiang Yu from Mulan
he's got some sidekicks too there's Isla
the daughter of yzma from the Emperor's
New Groove
there's also claw the set of scar from
The Lion King
however Shenmue discovers that there's a
way to break the magical barrier
surrounding the Isle of the Lost
but it could damage the descendents who
have gone over to our Don so Ouma Harry
and Gil find themselves having to join
forces with mal and her friends to stop
Shenmue we love this and we want to see
whether uma can find her inner strength
it seems that's something that a lot of
descendants to fans want to see in
descendants 3 is for uma to make a
comeback this idea is a great way to put
her into the story and introduce some
new characters and to let us see a new
side of China and MacLaine's character
and that's all for this is what fans
think descendants 3 will look like
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to the things
you